good morning everybody jay leno thank
you very much for doing this man thanks
thanks for having me I appreciate it
your your place is the most impressive
thing that I've ever seen someone own
your garage
I shouldn't say garage cuz everybody
thinks it's a garage you're on you have
twelve garages twelve giant warehouse
buildings filled with the most amazing
cars I've ever seen in my entire life
well a couple amazing a lot of them are
just old cars that I like that are kind
of fun I have a good story if cars got a
good story about it I liked how you
trying to downplay it but I'm just
telling you I was a fellow car nut thank
you not nearly of your proportion but I
was blown away that place is insane well
yeah your videos up right now people
love it it's almost a two hundred
thousand hits well thank you very much
for having me on I really appreciate it
was a lot of fun it was it was really
cool it was cool to be a passenger in my
car and have you drive around somebody
else beat the crap out of your car
what's more fun than that how did you
get started with such an insane
collection like what did you start out
with now used to work at car dealerships
when I was a kid I worked at a Ford
dealership I was in charge of odometer
recalibrations that was my area really
well you know you used to do back in the
old days like a guy would bring a car in
and then the boss would say I take it
the used car back and just turn back to
the speedometer okay I mean one guy came
in with like a 64 Chevy and I had like
ninety two thousand miles so he's making
this deal for his new Ford you know
buh-buh-buh and went back there with the
drills it's been in the back you know
this planet with a drill yeah so the guy
comes out he goes that no no give me my
car back cut now well that was cars him
at 15,000 miles on it and he drove away
and he went around the block and he came
back with a big smile on his face
because he knew he had the dealership
because he said and they gave him what
he wanted because we already turned the
clock so you could have caught him and
busted him like no no he's not like a
federal crime no now it is not caught
him I mean he could have caught you yeah
but yeah back in the day that's used car
dealers it was horrible is terrible I
was like I was a kid I was like really
this is what they do okay you know what
is the worst thing you ever saw them do
worse thing well well you know you used
to have stuff you want the undercoating
okay that's hundred 30 levels
undercoating and they put the car in the
rack and they take some black paint just
spray underneath you know it's like
cheap black rust-oleum paint and then
tell people is undercoating oh yeah the
car business really been cleaned up like
the scene from Fargo when they charge
them with yeah that's my favorite series
by the car with the old couple and it
just Yellin Adam a hilarious so you
started off just working on cars working
in dealerships and then some oil on when
I start collecting them well I realize
I'm never gonna have any nice cars
working at a car dealership you know
became a comedian yeah so became a
comedian so I thought that's like a good
way to make money at the time and it was
so yeah you're so in your element when
you're around cars and when you do that
show it's so different and you know and
and I said this with all due respect you
were great host of The Tonight Show
comic you know talking to like dopey
celebrities yeah I mean there are some
really interesting ones but then there's
me right yeah just really like reality
stuff yes and people like you probably
never saw that comment either when you
first started hosting the Tonight Show
there weren't reality stars they didn't
exist yeah that's true
but you know I really enjoyed it because
I like people I like talking to people
but a lot of times you don't really talk
to the person you talk to the publicist
mm-hmm I meant one time we had this ice
skater on like oh she's famous she's in
the Olympics and then like 10 years
later she was in Playboy magazine like
she hadn't done anything for ten years
then she's in Playboy so we got a call
from Playboy would you put so and so and
you know okay yeah she was America's
Sweetheart now she's naked okay that
could be interesting second guess okay
fine so she comes in and her manager
takes a mr. Longo high speed you we are
not mentioning the playboy article I go
really
why don't you take your client and go
home okay I get a comic here in four
minutes this is why your client is here
you called us because you're naked in
Playboy okay hilarious we will we are
not mentioning what you're here for
right exactly
exactly I mean that would happen all the
time just publicist would get mad
because you yeah the well the
manipulation of the image it's it's
really not that possible anymore because
the Internet
kind of all comes out you know it
doesn't it dot you know in the old days
when you watch old shows with Johnny you
see stars come out and they would just
make these horrible fashion mistakes or
whatever because they dress themselves
or they now everybody has handlers you
don't do this you don't do that don't
talk about the oh no don't talk about
that you know it so it gets a little
it's not quite as loose as it used to be
so you think that some because of
handlers and publicists and things long
as yeah everybody is handled by somebody
now or don't do this no don't kill don't
give her actual opinion let's just say
that we love everyone you know whatever
it might be
did you ever think about going back to
do a talk show on another networks like
them no it never even occurred to me you
know you can't make lightning strike
twice when we did The Tonight Show we
had a good crew I had a lot of stuff
left over from Johnny in terms of
editing facilities all this kind of
stuff and when you try and recreate that
again it cost you twice as much with
half the budget I mean Arsenio Hall is a
good buddy of mine and when I send you
know went to do his show again his hands
were tied
they gave him no budget you know I mean
god bless him he made it work as best he
could but like for example when a guest
would come out from a TV show the man
couldn't even play the theme song to the
TV show because they didn't have money
for music rights so you just had to play
like porn music you know I mean just
little things like that you don't even
think about you know those are that's
where the cost comes get any music
rights getting this getting that so no I
never thought about going to do it again
I did it for 22 years you know it was
number one when I got it it was number
one when I left that was perfect for me
how many you know this year in the fight
game how many fighters there champ there
champ there champ they come out of
retirement they get their ass kicked
yeah you know you you can't make it
strike twice well it with boxing and
ends
with you know fighting a lot of times it
ends really bad for a lot of the great
ones it's the saddest thing in the world
boxing always ends bad did you ever see
requiem for a heavyweight yeah we talked
about in the video my all-time favorite
movie Anthony Quinn just the greatest
actor and he goes in if you haven't seen
this movie you gotta get it because it's
got Cassius Clay man out Muhammad Ali
Cassius Clay and and he plays Mountain
Rivera and he he was ranked fifth
heavyweight in the world you know back
in the 50s in movie takes place in the
early 60s and he's still fighting and he
goes for a job at unemployment like it's
a dishwasher and it's this heartbreaking
way to go that was number five I was
number five in the world and the woman
looks at him like wow oh it's just a gut
wrenching scene and he replies it's it
must be awful to being a profession with
is only one number one like some people
think you're funny some people think I'm
funny some people use sex some people
think I said fine it's all subjective
there's only there's not one comedian
right and everybody else is ranked below
it's whatever you like you know as but
to be in a game like fighting where the
where it's so wonderful it must be tough
to be in a feel with that's if you're
the only guy yeah and your whole the
whole purpose of it is to dish out
destruction yet someone's gonna dish it
out to you and along the way you've
taken some and before you know it your
body just doesn't function the same way
my dad was a prizefighter that's what he
did how did he retire well I mean he
eventually sold in show movie than the
insurance company yeah you know my dad
grew up in in New York and during the
Depression and I never know how far my
dad got in school he never actually tell
us you know but I know he quit and he
became a prizefighter for a while and
then he became a Salesman because he's
pretty good with kids so we would always
watch the fights together that was
my dad and I always did Wow did he ever
try to get you to do it well yeah we
played around a little bit with it but
it was just not my I don't have that I
don't have that killer instinct I don't
hit the guy in the face you know it just
it was it was not me it was not me I had
a couple of fights when I was a teenager
and it was like oh man you know there's
nothing like getting your ass kicked to
put things in perspective you know most
people have never had the crap beat out
of them and when you've had that happen
to you a couple of times you begin to
appreciate the art of negotiation I
number of people I meet in this town let
me tell you some if I ever see that guy
I'm gonna kick no you're not you're not
gonna kick his ass because look at you
and look at him okay he's a street guy
you went to la-dee-da College he just
knows stuff you don't know it's not
gonna happen but they have this they've
never had the crap kicked at him so they
just have this attitude that just makes
me laugh yeah I think it's healthy for
every man to get punched in the face at
least once in his life just to get
humility yeah a little bit I think yeah
knocked out I got knocked out a couple
of times and I would see the cartoons
where they see stars and I go that's
kind of silly no you actually see stars
I start twinkling I saw twinkling things
it's just like the cartoon I've never
going down that one just like the
cartoon when I hit the floor yeah
there's a lot of people especially in
Hollywood that think that fighting is
like a movie like you could just piss to
whip somebody yeah that always drove me
crazy we just whack a guy over the head
they just they go out and they wake up
but other than that fine well the funny
thing about movies is whether you're the
good boy good guy the bad guy the punch
is always thrown from the perspective of
the person throwing the punch I've never
seen a movie where the punch is coming
at you you know what I mean right so
it's always over the shoulder so as the
viewer you're always throwing the punch
that always makes I want to see a movie
where the punch is coming in hitting you
in the face while you're sitting there
in the theater yeah you don't really get
that but yeah where you can see the
sparks and
what it happens when the punches hit
your face that's my light show that's my
favorite thing about these superhero
movies you see the superhero he punches
a car and the car folds up like an
accordion and then he punches the other
superhero and the guy goes oh oh man
yeah well no I didn't his face get
crushed like the car just did I don't
quite understand cuz it's a movie Jay
Leno it's not real life exactly just
just a little escape sort of like The
Tonight Show you left on top you like
that that is rare that someone leaves
number one usually want to keep you
around everybody left The Tonight Show
it was number one Steve on the left one
is number one Jack Paar laughing it was
number one Johnny left foot it was
number one I left no what did you do
miss it at all no no I had your time you
enjoyed it I loved doing it you know
this there's a point your life where at
my age I shouldn't have to know all the
Jay Z's music okay I mean I'm sorry I
don't I can't pretend to know yeah
common and everybody's music I just
don't it's you know notice how you
brought up a lot of black cars I grew up
in the era of Paul Simon and Marvin Gaye
and all those get small my it's more my
era you know when you're 20 when you're
42 when you're talking to 25 year old
supermodel oh it's sexy when you're 64
you like the creepy old guy right so
what do you go to school you know save
you okay I'm like 40 years older than
you are
what am I gonna say to you you know so
you just have to know when it's time to
stuff but your your demeanor your what
what your excitement level how natural
is when you're doing your car show is
very different and I think people would
I I think there's two jay leno's there's
the Jay Leno that hosts the Tonight Show
which is a great entertainer you're a
great interviewer but then there's you
in your element when you're a host in
Jays my gosh I tell you something I
enjoy being around show business as
opposed to being immersed in it like to
me Charlie Sheen's a friend of mine I
enjoy every time another hooker pushes
one of Charlie's SATs off Mulholland
Drive I get a kick out of it like
everybody I don't want to be Charlie
live that life buddy my enjoy hearing
about it and observing Charlie when he
comes to the show Charlie how you doing
man Oh Jagger whatever it might be so
the tonight show's great that way I
didn't have to actually be there I could
be a part of it without being a part of
it right now right because it's not
really I'm not really a party guy I'm
not a drug guy I'm not an alcohol guy
you know it's just not what I do I enjoy
observing it whereas with cars it's what
I really do cars motorcycles
I really just so I am immersed in that
whereas with show business I enjoy being
around it you know but you still do
stand-up so you're still yeah I'm on the
road all I'd love to understand it
that's the greatest so you're still in
show business oh yeah I'm still in show
business yeah
but you're not in that show business
yeah it's like comics will think of
stand up as being very different than
all the other aspects of show business
well it is different than all the other
aspects of show business because it's
the only one where you don't need any
other aspects of show business I mean I
got started when I was in Boston I would
go into bars with a $50 bill and I I
would say I'm a comedian we don't hire
comedians I go look it was fifty bucks
let me go on the stage to tell some jobs
if people leave you keep my 50 if I do
okay I get some laughs give me my money
back
all right cost you about $300 a lot but
for the most part it was either yeah kid
you a funny here's your money back but
you know me you don't really just or
okay yeah come back Wednesday come back
Wednesday we got a back then they had
hootenanny night it was folk singers
stop you more machine you know all those
kind of songs and they put a comic on in
between and that's the one thing about
comedy you can take it and do it
anywhere I mean we both know actors that
are great that are funny but if their TV
show gets canceled or the movies no good
or the director yeah it's like they're
out of work they can't go down to a bar
and pass the Hat and tell jokes or even
negotiate a salary it's you know so
comedy is different because it's it's
self-sustaining hootenanny night yeah
that's what used to call them ball
really
yeah Wow yeah so you really did that you
would go is that your idea to put a $50
bill yeah because that's you know I was
lucky when I started I'd never met
another comic I didn't know anything
about show business you know you know
your Boston you're from Ella from Boston
rather and I remember the neighbour lady
saying to me you know you can't be a
comedian lest you find there was a
comedian that's the way it is out there
unless your father was a comedian you
can't you can't be one then won't let
you do it you know what I thought
doesn't make any sense so I used to just
go around bars and places like that in
Boston and I thought I was doing pretty
good you know I really wasn't but to me
I thought it was pretty good I got my
start at a place called Lenny's on the
Turnpike up and Route one near Saugus I
know that I used to play nice all the
time
and Lenny made me kind of the house
comic and I got to work with Miles Davis
Mose Allison all the great jazz artists
Wow
that's where giggles is and Saugus up
there in a place Prince's pizza yeah I
mean like Clark's joint it makes me
laugh Lenny Clark's brother was that
ladies I know honey Clark the funniest
guy he really and a true Boston comedian
you know I never get sent myself a
Boston comedian because I was born in
New York and I moved to Boston I was
like 10 like my family moved there in 59
and we're still the new people know
people that Leno's they came here in 59
you know the other people have been
there since building 41 right exactly
you know so they're you know they're the
relatively new people did you did they
have open mic nights back then no there
was no such thing as open mic me this is
before comedy clubs the comedy clubs
didn't equate here did you start
I started 1969 Wow and I used to work
strip joints I used to work you know you
remember the combat zone and Shore yeah
I used to work all those strip joints I
worked I remember I I teamed up with two
strippers Lily pagan and I need a man
that was her name
and they were like 40 years old and they
were like they weren't prostitutes
they were they were working-class women
big Boston women with short hair that
would wear wigs and like we would drive
out to Fort Devens to do a show with the
soldiers
they'd be there with drills and in the
you know power tools and they put and
she put together this this what do you
call that clear plastic they have
plexiglass Plexiglas bathtub and and she
would take a bath you know like a
stripper you know and so and they were
tough women and I was like 19 and they
were like 40 and one day we're out doing
a show and she's in the bathtub you know
doing those kind of stuff and I'm on
stage just telling jokes said so until
and some guy just thoughts heckling me
and I remember she gets out of the
bathtub walks over grabs a guy by neck
punches him in the face breaks the guy's
nose the guy goes down the crowd is
cheering she leave the kid alone then
she gets back in the tub but starts
doing it was hilarious
it was hilarious Wow oh great it was a
great time and they were really nice
women they weren't hookers you know
these are women that back then being a
typist or a secretary that's really what
was available to you as a woman if you
were not a college-educated woman you
know or a waitress or something like
that so that's what they did they they
had the car with their you know stripper
insignia on the side I need a man and
you know that kind of a dolled up
picture of themselves payment on the
fender and we just drive around and I
would emcee and introduce the girls and
they would come out and do their act you
know but they were very protective of me
because I was like a kid Wow yeah it was
it was really fun that's got to be cool
memory oh god no like that it's so much
more difficult than the standard signed
up at the open mic night I started in 88
it was just a to have stitches would
have an open mic night yeah oh there you
sign up and you know you'd get on three
of them for the comedy boom is fairly
new I mean when I started I used to go
to the I went to the improv of New York
in 69 and the improv them bad bro is say
okay four singers than you because it
was all Broadway singer that's all the
way there really wasn't a lot of people
the one to become
because most comedians in the mid to
late 60s were middle-aged Jewish guys
like Rodney Alan King the first new
young comics were like Robert Klein
Richie Pryor George Carlin
don't forget Richie Pryor yeah I used to
call Richie going to Richie yeah yeah
Wow Richie I've never heard him say
Richie Pryor you gotta remember in New
York City up to about 66 67
you got what they call a cabaret card
which was a license you had a license to
be an entertainer and if you use to fall
out a word onstage a cop could come in
pull your license tear it up you didn't
work you could not work Lenny Bruce
really helped break that because Lenny
went to trial for you know for that
that's what you that's what he's
arrested for he's just doing his act you
know he used to do a bit about if you
don't like black I mean who would you
rather have sex with Lena Horne or Kate
Smith what Kate Smith was an enormous
woman at the time and it was a funny
joke and oh that's so that's a racist so
that's whatever you can't do that and I
remember a cop pulled his license and he
went to court he eventually won and they
did away with the whole cabaret license
thing so
most comedians were middle-aged Jewish
guys had talked about the kids today
with the long you know what it has so
long to patch it to a damn tie to tell
you that these kids they look like a
jack deck like a chili smelt like a John
these hippies outside and that was what
that's what guys did nobody talked
stream-of-consciousness nobody did what
what Richie in and and and George Carlin
I remember George when George was just a
straight stand-up and then he became the
hippie dippie weatherman and then he had
this radical change to the George Carlin
we know now but he was the George used
to be in a comedy team actually really
with who with um I it's named as me but
I forgot yeah I've seen some of his
early early stuff yeah it's fascinating
to look at him because he was such such
a different guy yeah the fascinating one
is also Rodney because before Rodney had
the no respect hook cuz Rodney was Jack
Roy for you
hey Jack Roy he was Nets his real name
Rodney worked and he couldn't make it
and then he became an aluminum siding
salesman and then he came back at age 44
is Rodney Dangerfield Wow he Rodney had
amused by the name of Joe ANSYS Joe
ANSYS was one of those guys who was not
a comedian himself because he was too
shy but was really funny he was a guy
all the comedians love to hang out with
because he would do table comedy you
know you'd sit with four or five comics
that it decanters type place or a deli
at 2:00 in the morning and he would just
riff and awe all the comics would just
sit there with pens and pencils caught
me down with one because he was so funny
but he couldn't he couldn't physically
bring himself to get on state he just
couldn't do it
and he he was a guy that helped I
remember Rodney used to do bits and when
you hear it one of his earlier he's got
a funny one about being an airline pilot
where he says that this is Rodney's joke
not mine obviously but he says hey folks
you look at that right left side of the
plane you could see the Empire State
Building women look out the right side
of the plane in New Jersey there you
could see the remains of Flight 418
which crashed in a fiery bald and that
field over there Bob you with me on that
one weren't you you know I used to make
me laugh when he did that and then
suddenly riding to became the hole with
the one-liner guy but before that he was
like a traditional comedian so how much
time did he take off in between coming
back it was like 10 years right no easy
he raised the family rodney was a good
guy I don't know if you ever really quit
I mean he quit hitting it hard
mm-hmm he was selling the Illuma siding
and doing all that kind of stuff having
a group what a great story have a
regular job that's why everybody uses
aluminum siding is sort of the bad job
because it's a job Rodney had you know
yeah rodney was a great story and I mean
truly funny guy and the fact that he
came back at 44 and just became an icon
yeah it's really an amazing story well
sometimes you have to grow into your act
yeah you know when you're 19 or 20 and
you're fresh-faced kid
you don't look like - no respect you
know Rodney needed to grow into that you
know look I tell you you know what the
you know the hangdog look and the tie
that's too tight and the cheap share it
but button didn't look like he'd be
choked to death I mean it was a great
groan of the great comedy prison I used
to work at great woods in Mansfield do
you know what that is yeah yeah I was a
security guard out there and I got to
see a lot of Acts yeah see Cosby out
there and Kinnison and when I was
working I got to see Rodney and this is
when Rodney was in his complete not give
a [ __ ] stay right where he wore a
bathrobe yeah that's what he would go
onstage with yes sir rodney was
backstage and you know I'm working in
the backstage area and you get to see
Rodney like there was a door was open to
his dressing room Rodney's hanging out
back there walking around pacing
slippers on bathrobe nothing on
underneath and the bathrobes open yeah
he's gonna dick like a horse yeah right
he's just allegedly I didn't see it yeah
but it was like I was like look at this
guy like this guy really doesn't like
some people will pretend to not give a
[ __ ] this guy really didn't give a [ __ ]
his hair was all crazy and he would go
onstage with the bathrobe and I couldn't
believe it
yeah I was 19 at the time right Rodney
let me live in his it danger feels a
nightclub there was a storage closet in
the back and I lived in that for a
couple of weeks really yeah they're just
a cot in there and you you know with
piles of sangria whatever they got to
sit just all the liquor and that's where
I stayed you lived in Dangerfield just
that's where I slept during the day but
Wow
I worked that Club a lot when I first
moved to New York New York was an
interest you know it's funny that when I
was just getting started
those are the last days of the old mob
clubs they don't really have mob run
joints anymore but those were really
really scary I remember I worked a club
once and a guy come up stage and he said
there you a funny kidney put a hundred
dollar bill in my pocket you know and I
said oh well thank you sir no no I
appreciate it as no please you know give
it to the church or donation as I might
tell you
I don't know you know no I can't through
that I really didn't earn it thank you
but please give it to maybe a waitress
and then he said to me you know you're
pretty smart you don't take money from
people like me
that's very smart nobody's gonna bother
you I said okay thank you sir and I
realized early on the guys had got in
trouble were the guys that wanted to
hang with the mob guys and then mob guys
hey it's a favor deliver this package to
the hotel we yeah sure okay now they're
screwed now they're in right and then
once years ago my wife why would I went
to New York and I was working the
Westchester premiere theatre and there
was a guy named Jimmy the weasel Friday
honey ever had that name Jimmy the
weasels look great yeah anyway so these
two guys museum mr. Lane house mr. Lee
knows you know this is Rocco DiSpirito
so we're in the back seat is Cadillac
you know so I'm teasing my wife and I
just kind of whispered her I didn't
think the guys get him I said you know
if I go into the city tonight I think
I'm gonna need a piece and this guy goes
oh mr. Lowe no police he takes a gun out
he throws in the bank goes please take
that one I said no I was like it no no
please there's no numbers on it just you
don't need to do nothing with it when
you're through just throw it in the
trash you know you know usually you know
you just throw it away I said I don't
know please I insist
okay thank you now I got this gun in my
wife is just like sweating bullets she's
like where are we worked out okay it was
just just funny you know just odd well
they ran Vegas they ran night clubs in
New York
oh yeah how did all that die what
happened corporations corporations are
meaner and nastier to the no oh then
within a month oh wait wait wait were at
least a mob you got a free drink once in
a while you got a look would you lose a
grand love me with the restaurant go it
of it not what's the corporation's come
in it with you had to be a bizarre time
to come up it was really man you know
it's really funny it's like you always
see gangsters on TV but when you're
confronted by true Psychopaths it is
unbelievable
you know I I told the story with Jerry
once on his community and coffee but I
didn't hear it okay I got a car I could
call one day from
Sinatra he says AJ this is the Sons of
Italy dinner in Italy can you do it when
is it he gives me the date and I said Oh
mr. Sinatra I'm it's a holiday house in
Pennsylvania with the sons of the
pioneers that's with you
I said I'm opening for them on that day
I'd love to do it for anybody can't do
it oh okay thing I said uh police
anything a couple hours way to get a
call from Sinatra's agent hey we called
the holiday house they said they don't
need you well they don't need you all
right guess I'm going to Chicago so I go
to Chicago I'm not gonna use any real
names because their people are still
around so we're doing this thing it's at
a golf course
and they say to me listen there's a
priest here okay so keep your act you
know I said okay fine
so I got when I do my little act - fine
thank you applause applause I sit down
so this gangster guy gets up you know
goes on welcome you all to this you
notice this place and wasn't gonna say
[ __ ] I think I was gonna say and when he
said [ __ ] the priest went like this okay
what hey father
you got your 10 grand in the [ __ ] bag
it just goes crazy in his gun
and the place is just everybody's just
just frozen with fear this guy's just
like crazy and the priest is like he's
holding his bag with the 10 grand a day
you know and then he sits now okay so
I'm sitting then the guy call AJ come in
just let me ask you something you know
Stallone right I said I don't know I'm a
rocky just come out this is 1976
everything I said I don't know I mean I
met him you know we asked him to do this
dinner
it's benefit today and he said no he
said no and I said well I mean maybe he
was busy screaming at me I go you're
right I'm sure I'm fine he goes uh he
goes uh this is come on let's play some
golf
i'm sanna we play golf I'll play golf
please and now our golf carts and might
win this golf cart we drive out to about
the 12th hole and we get to 12th hole
and there are these kind of 50 60 year
old prostitutes topless with leopard
skin print miniskirts handing out drinks
it was like the craziest day of my life
but this guy was like a true psycho
criminal I mean just one of those guys
like a scene from Goodfellas they just
kill you you know I always loved movies
where somebody threatened someone they'd
go you're not gonna kill me Bob cuz I
know you're not that kind of guy
no no they will kill you they will kill
you and it just really made me laugh is
that guy still alive I may still be
alive
really yeah this is a while ago he's
probably dead by now because he was an
old guy then yeah it seems like a guy
like dad's not gonna make it I'll tell
you okay isn't it no he made it through
with it she made it
Wow just hilarious you know so you don't
really have those I'm sure you have
still have those guys but very very
rarely they're not Italians anymore
these Russian well there's always one
one organized crime group that sort of
dominates the market yeah
it just it's just really odd it was it
was a fun time to be a comedian but you
had to weave your way through for a teen
you know Morey Amsterdam in the comic I
heard his name yeah he used to be on
them on the Dick Van Dyke Show yes yeah
well he got famous because he was Al
Capone's favorite comedian Al Capone
would always come in to see him
Wow so Al would put him in a like I know
Al Capone would put him in his clubs and
that's how Maury Maury really got famous
because Al Capone loved him thought he
was hilarious you know but imagine if
you don't make Al Capone laugh she puts
a lot of pressure yeah yeah hilarious
what's he like we got nice diamonds cuz
a comedy club
there weren't comedy clubs they were
just either jazz club C jazz clubs were
great for comedians because jazz
audiences listen rock clubs were bad and
during the late sixties comedy was kind
of mentality it's were very serious you
know everybody do those little plays
where this stage is dark and you'd like
to flash light under your chin stop your
war machine
click and then turn it off and then the
guys run to another part of the stage
click stop your war machine clicking
turn you know it's all this conceptual
kind of so comedy was really on the back
burner it really took Pryor in Karlin
and Robert Klein and those guys to make
it really pop again for young people
what was it before that I mean when when
were the first they say that Mark Twain
was probably the first recognized
stand-up comedian because he used to do
these monologues and readings of his
work oh sure
and he would do them in front of a live
audience people would laugh you know
stand-up is like jazz it's a uniquely
American art form like when you go to
England stand-ups over there maybe come
out in a dress and they sing a song to
do a skit or they do a little dance I
mean now they have American style sandal
but the idea of I always like comics
would look like normal people
but were funny I was never a fan of the
wacky prop so the crazy has like Johnny
Carson Pryor Cosby Klein Carlin sir
these guys look like regular guys you
see in the street and then when they
talked oh my god they were really really
funny
those that something that really came
later cuz most stand-up came out of
vaudeville we had to that's what my
mother used to say to me all the time
when I got sad you know no one wants
someone that's funny all the time why
don't you sing a little song and then
you do a little dance and then you tell
it okay - great advice thanks I really
appreciate that's what they used to do
right yeah that's what they used to do
that's so bizarre it's so crazy that it
happened in your lifetime I mean you
went from doing those original clubs to
being around
I mean you regularly work at the comedy
& magic Club which is like one of the
biggest clubs in the country I've been
there every Sunday since 78 and when
you're not there I've been there yeah
it's it's you know I like it I like that
Club because it's the best mainstream
audience Club you know the Hollywood
clubs are great but it winds up being
clicky you're doing you know you're
doing twenty minutes on a little shop on
Melrose that maybe you half-a-dozen
people know about and the audience is
hysterical the rest of the world's going
went you know yeah you've got to you've
got to have a broader appeal and when
you go to the comedy magic club a lot of
that audiences overnight is from the
airport they missed the plane whatever
the stand in a local hotel Oh
see what this is so you get people from
all over the country yeah it's a great
place anyway just Mike Lacey's just such
an awesome guy yeah he's a great guy
he's probably the best clever one in
there is one of the best of all time
he's such a sweetheart
just it's like a trickle down from the
top to the bottom all that work there
it's a amazing spot but you were there
for like the you seen the Muny movie
Lenny with Dustin Hoffman and Bruce when
he they showed the early days of Lenny's
comedy we're used to work with strippers
and all these different acts and tell a
few jokes and be like an MC honey Harlow
I think that yeah he married a stripper
you know it's interesting Dustin
Hoffman's one of the greatest actors but
I never bought that he was a stand-up
you know stand-up is so uniquely
different from acting when people act
like a stand-up you know I'm anxious to
see Mike Epps now I'm I heard it's gonna
play Richie Pryor it's very interesting
to see because he's a comic mm-hmm so he
understands how that works
actors tend to watch themselves when
they're on stage by that I mean
whereas comics just perform they don't
really care if their face looks funny or
whatever it is your comic just
performing you know so when actors play
comedians it never quite works for me as
well as a comedian plane ticket me well
the worst example is the punch line with
Tom Hanks and Sally Fields that's I
didn't see that one but I heard about
don't know save yourself it's one of
those movies were you watching you go
what the [ __ ] am I looking at I'm
looking at an optical illusion there's
something behind the scenes here that's
not really it's not they're not really
doing stand-up but the people are
laughing hard yeah it because it's hard
to write jokes there's nothing harder
than writing jokes that's what I hate
about because one of you watch a movie
as a stand-up any like a TV show tough
so I said to him on Thursday and then
the audience goes hilarious no right to
hold joke okay they always do that's
because it's hard it's hard writing job
well not only that but a real comic is
not gonna want to write jokes for an
actor like if I have a good joke you're
writing it good juggler I don't keep
this one for me exactly [ __ ] shitty
one the Tom Hanks over here exactly
so you you saw the boom though in the
80s because there was a big boom in the
80s I came along like I caught the crest
I was I was there
when when I started out people like why
I should have started out in 84 84 I was
amazing
I started in 88 and it was just like
right in Boston in particular it was a
pretty magical time it was a magical
time it was also you know to me you have
a lot of people now that rush to the
middle and then stay there but 20 years
and never quite get because you know I
sound like an old guy here but when I
started you had to work clean I mean
it's really easy to take a clean joke
and make it dirty it's almost impossible
to take a really funny dirty joke and
make it clean it just it doesn't work
and when the punchline is some four
little word what do you do with that
where do you go with it you can't take
it past a certain point if you're trying
to get on television well if you're
trying to get on television you're
trying to get any corporate work you
know there's two Americas that really
are there's one over here and one over
here and if you can have a foot in both
of them you can do really well for
example most corporate dates will pay
you ten weeks worth of Comedy Club
salaries in one night if you can just
work clean and and by working clean I
just mean no four-letter words you can
talk politics you can do whatever you
want but the number of comics that can't
get past a certain point because they
hit that wall you know they rush right
up to it and it's it's like horse power
it's like being an athlete plenty of
guys can play football
how many can get it past that certain
you know the average athlete is what one
in 10,000 and the average superstar is
what one in two or 300,000 and if you
want to be that superstar you've got to
work you've got to appeal to a more of a
mass audience that's an interesting way
of looking at it a lot of people would
disagree and they would say that all
they want to do is do the best comedy or
the best art that they can come up with
and it's not necessarily something that
a corporation is going to want a high
well I'm not saying but no yeah I think
you're missing my point what I'm saying
is
what most people do is they want to play
the audience where they get the best
laugh mm-hmm okay I just go I just do
colleges I just do hip little cool
places mm-hmm you know I a couple times
I booked myself into Oral Roberts
University once just to see if I could
play the gig this is a challenge just as
a challenge like signing up for a
triathlon and you know you know a
perfect example of that was when Richie
Pryor was getting ready to do his live
on the Sunset Strip a movie movie Oh
stand up I asked them could I follow
Richie every single night and Richie
would go up from for 90 minutes just
blow the room out it's a comedy story I
mean people falling down I mean it was
the greatest interview ever seen and
then I would go on and I realized at
that point instead of having an hour's
worth of funny material I had about 18
minutes because I was following the
greatest comic in the world and my good
stuff was okay my okay stuff was yeah
and my aunt stuff was terrible but if
you just play rooms where everybody
laughs at everything you say you never
get any better right you know I remember
Robin Williams once said to me he said
I'm gonna do some stuff tonight where
you watch it and okay and they blatant
this is the height of Mork and Mindy
late and gentlemen with Robin Williams
Wow oh the crowd and no matter what
Robin said hilarious and that Robin came
off what he said
I mean that new stuff funny I said
really it wasn't because they were
reacting to Robin the phenomenon I mean
obviously Robin could put a twist on and
I'm not putting down Robins interiorly
I'm just saying I know you know but he
knew after listening to it which part of
it really was funny and what wasn't so
the idea of eyeballs on one of those
people if you're a comic you should be
able to play any type of audience if
you're a fighter you should be able to
fight anybody
all right no I only fight tall skinny
black guys no no no no I you should be
able to play for any kind of room so
whatever here comics say well I don't do
that or you know people are people you
know that that's pretty much what it is
yeah there's a there's definitely like
cliques in LA all of this people that
only like to do alternative rooms and
you know which are much more accepting
of very bland and that's fine yeah hey
I'm not putting it down there's nothing
wrong with that
but when you don't make it you can't
blame it on well the eye or some people
go well this audience was really stupid
no they're not they're not stupid you
just didn't get your point across you
know a lot of comedians want to impress
an audience with how much they know know
itself they'll say the anthropomorphic
tendency you know why don't you just say
yeah that's how dogs are like people act
like humans okay now I know what you're
talking about okay if you don't know
what anthropomorphic means the jobs not
gonna work but you want to impress
everybody how smart you are by throwing
out anthropomorphic you know comedians
sometimes always have an underlying
thing they want to get some point across
I remember a comedian was on The Tonight
Show once and his opening line was you
know I'm a liberal Democrat and I said
to him don't open why don't just do the
material we will figure out your
politics within a minute and a half of
your set but when you say to yourself
here's what I am you already lost half
the crowd I mean I don't think most
people could figure out my politics from
the monologue because I tried to
humiliate and degrade everybody equally
so one night hola no you and your
Republican friend oh no no you and your
Democratic buddies I hope you're happy
what you said about mr. Bush you know so
that was the perfect thing when they got
complaints on both sides well what you
were doing back then - by by going to
these different bars you kind of had to
have a bulletproof act you kind of had
to have an act that would work on
virtually any kind of a club yeah that's
what you tried to do I mean it didn't
always work my face always right but you
kind of had to formulate something and
and the real trick was when you get
famous somewhere get the hell out of
there I mean I knew so many great comics
in Boston that were really funny but
their material is all about what happens
in Boston then they go to Connecticut or
New York and didn't work
then it doesn't work so to me once I
realized oh I'm getting kind of a name
for me here I've got to go someplace
where nobody knows who I am and then I
would go to the next place you
and start all over again that's amazing
that you knew that though at the time I
could feel it you know old we you 20 21
and you see it already figured that out
when you're 21 you know this comics are
inherently lazy they go to where the
laughs are I just can't play that room
you know yeah I do better there they
they know me they like my stuff there
but once you go to the room where you
suck because if you can get big laughs
in the room where you suck right now you
have two rooms you can go to now you got
three I mean I sort of pride myself on
being able to play any kind of gig
what's the gig this bubble the only the
only one that was really bad was I did
Christian farmers and I realized oh my
god things I wouldn't even thought the
least bit objectionable weirdo just
horrible okay like what do you remember
oh I just Christian farmer yeah that was
the audience you know it was just I
can't remember what the jokes were but
just you know any couldn't do a joke
about masturbation anything you know
just things that were normal everyday no
that was horrible you know that when
I've is read I noticed in Boston when I
started doing road gigs that I had all
this great material that I could use in
town that was local stuff about like say
girls from Revere with their crazy hair
girls from Revere were known for having
these what we call bulletproof hair
right they would have [ __ ] sprayed
hair that was like a mile high it was
like this crazy time in the 80s
well they had these giant hairdos yeah
and I would it was a great bit in town
and Boston I would do that bit it would
kill right I would go to Connecticut it
would just die of vicious there's my
best [ __ ] you ever worked at
Beachcomber and everywhere
no I never I don't think comma just
closed I worked that place back in the
early 70s and I remember the guys hey
hey when you come in don't wear your
best clothes what it just don't wear
your best clothes why
I couldn't figure sorry I want my best
clothes alright so I'm on stage and I
realize the people in front road they'd
smoke the cigarettes down to the butt
and then they flicking at you you know
so I'm on stage once and one lands on my
shoulder you know and I don't see it but
I hear as I'm sending the joke up I hear
people laughing I go oh I'm doing pretty
good
and then look up Hey look and my jackets
on fire because this guy flicked a
cigarette and it caught fire and then
the guy said to me afterwards I told you
weren't the way you good clothes I said
Don Wright y'all do that next time just
make me laugh Jesus Christ hell it was
funny
Joey Cola told me who was doing pips in
Brooklyn once and there was a guy that
was sitting in the front row that kept
telling I'm [ __ ] you [ __ ] I [ __ ] hate
you you're not funny
and the Newcomen's gone lift up his
shirt and show his gun and then you know
you know Joey cold you know Joey he's a
sweetheart
hey you know he's like real like high
energy real happy guy and this guy's
just showing him his gun and saying [ __ ]
you
oh yeah there's just things that you
don't I had so many night I had so many
nightmare gigs one of my worst was
opening for Tom Jones for two weeks
every night in Vegas two weeks so I get
there the opening night and I walk out
and there were 300 women or maybe 350
women in the Tom Jones fan club and they
bought tickets to every show and they
had assigned seats so I walk out the
first night and then I see these 300
women the first 10 or 15 rows there's a
dinner show then so it wasn't it wasn't
theater seating like no okay I do my act
and I do okay I'm terrible I'm real good
okay I got the second night and the same
women are in the same seats and I'm
doing the same Act
I get nothing okay by show 9 it's like
hey Mary hey sue how you doing I guess
it's the same 300 women every single
night and in their mind you see me being
on stage is less time that Tom's doing
right now
don't get the concept there's an opening
act but the most humiliating part was I
come offstage
oh my Gus is awful and I walk out
through the front and this girl goes hey
great show I said oh thank you she looks
at me like I said thank you thank you
very much I said how are you good
I'm gonna get a bite sure okay I'm
talking this girl for a few minutes and
she I see she's getting a patient you
know she the look we've gone upstairs it
or what I not what well I realized she
was a hooker work in the room she said
good show I thought she'd seen the show
she's a good show to anybody to walk out
I said oh you didn't see the show know
who you I said oh I'm the guy well you
wasted my time in that she stomps out no
hope then the whole coffee shop looka
little guy couldn't game how bad is that
guy that hooker walked out on it's
harmless what year was this Oh 76 I
would love to go back in time to those
days god I would love to go back just to
see what it was like well it was really
any different than now I mean you're on
stage or the microphone it really wasn't
a whole lot different I mean what the
culture must have been so different the
culture was different you know Freddie
Prinze was a good friend of mine you
remember Freddie yes Freddie used to
stay with me when he worked the Playboy
Chico in the man he could when the man
played the Playboy Club in Boston and
there the Playboy you had to do six
shows a night he had the penthouse in
the play room and I remember I had to
there was a singer and I had I would
open and then she would take her band to
come upstairs and I would pass her in
the hallway she'd be carrying these drum
sets because the musicians they don't
have to move the round-trip singer has
to move the drums and big sweat stains
under her arms and she'd be in tears by
the fourth show she just looked like she
would but beat up but anyway Freddie's
on stage and he's talking about Nixon
and he said I think the jokey so the
President Nixon whatever blah blah blah
and this guy knew I had to say you watch
your mouth you know it's a brother you
know it's date and Fred and when he said
a Nixon doesn't
doesn't through something he sucks well
this guy takes out a gun stops firing it
over Freddie's head you know she's a
chutes it into the cut and the whole
club just hits the ground you know just
just crazy stuff that really doesn't
happen a whole lot anymore
where was this club was this Boston Wow
yeah Jesus Christ I thought clubs are
actually great you know people they
exist anymore they still do but Hugh
Hefner I give him credit he was the
first guy no he was the first guy to let
blacks walk through the front door that
Club and play in the club Dick Gregory
Louie Armstrong all these acts he
treated them as equals
which today you think wasn't know in the
old days black performance had to go in
through the kitchen half always you came
in through the front door and you were
treated with respect if anybody said
anything racial in that nature you got
thrown out of the club so he was really
sort of a pioneer and being you know
equality for performance so I always I
mean I've done a million Hugh Hefner
jokes as everybody else but I always
give him credit for that usually he was
really great that way well he certainly
he's always been on sort of the cutting
edge socially I know certain so yeah I
mean now in a sense you know now it
seems like it's kind of silly but yeah
well it's a hard gig to hold on to you
know he was at the Disneyland recently
and I was you know Disneyland they give
you that VIP pass if you're famous
person right okay you get to go through
the exits right I didn't know about that
back then and so he had gotten into the
ride before you know he hadn't gotten
the one I just sort of walked him in
through the back door so all sudden he
was there with like this captain's hat
on with these two girls that just had
their faces spray-painted on yeah like
this is the oddest thing that this guy
does it's just so odd yeah I just it
does seem [ __ ] is he's so old yeah yet
he's still hanging around I'm like
trying to piece it together for like the
next hour like does he enjoy this still
or is this just like a publicity angle
I'll take my fare back in 76
Schwarzenegger and I get invited to half
25th anniversary party comfortable
mention Dre and you know some are like
God I knew Arnold
Arnold was enormous then he's like twice
the size he is them yeah so with the
hanging around and then have says to me
you know Jerry would you like to have
lunch with the girls for the girls
I said sure that'd be great so I go into
this dining room and it's a beautiful
mansion but it looks like a frat house
you know it's all the wood is chipped
indented on the part ISM there's a big
long table no chairs about half a dozen
of the Playboy Bunnies hanging around
you know in street clothes I was and
this Butler guy walks in with the
biggest bucket of Kentucky Fried Chicken
I'd ever seen it looked like a trash can
he just puts it down and all the girls
dive in and grab a piece of chicken I
said really this is the playboy
lifestyle this is a bucket of Kentucky
Fried Chicken I got like a garbage can
full of so he feeds them like the way
you would feed chickens right my own
chicken area let's put the food out in
the olds there you go that's a that's a
weird place the if you go by the grotto
they still have the old phones like the
old yeah a buddy of mine went there this
is like it sounds like an old joke but
it's a funny story so he goes he's never
been before and he's like really nervous
so he's walking down by the grotto and
he sees a couple of girls naked in the
pool so he hides behind a tree and he's
watching and he's watching he's watching
him and he's so nervous he takes out his
cigarette smoking and security works up
gresling goes hey no smoking huh he just
thought he'd get busted no he got busted
for smoking it just made me laugh that
is very funny just so stupid yeah I was
there for I hosted him
it was either marijuana policy project
or normal I can't remember who who had
it but I hosted this this event that
they had there a fundraising event and
it was very strange to be around the
grotto and just to be in this place just
to think of all the things that have
happened in that place out of odd you
know you got a lot of old guys guys my
age now and girls are going oh look what
James Franciscus gave me oh yeah
beautiful ring you know whatever just
some old movie star from the 80s you
know hilarious it's just hanging on yeah
trying their best
yeah well if you're still in the game
every now and then a pitch comes your
way you got it right that's right
low-hanging fruit so when you're in your
day when you when you started out doing
these strange clubs and you know
hootenannies and all and all that jazz
how long was it before the comedy club
came around how was that how was that
received comedy club came around the
beginning of the eighties probably so
like right when I I start in 88 so when
they were talking about like 84 that was
really when I kind of really started out
what's out of the the peak and then it
then cuz you know the comedy clubs in
the 80s probably paid more money than
that you now really yeah yeah and then
they realize they realized oh there's a
million comics we don't have to pay
these guys anything and then the price
went way down by with a 50% drop way way
off because in the early days there
weren't that many comedians who really
weren't aware I was when I went to New
York go to the improv there may be three
comedians and like 10 singers Wow
audition night now everybody wants to be
a comedian but by then back then it
really was not what it is now what was
it about comedy that just drew you to it
because it seems like that is not an
easy path back then it seemed like
there's no direct route like now you can
go to the comedy store you sign up for
potluck night and you know if you go
enough nights in a row you're eventually
gonna get on stage yeah you know for me
I was dyslexic as a kid so I really
wasn't good anything except just talking
and it's or bullshitting whatever might
be and you know I I used to like to
watch comedians on TV and I thought well
this might be a fun thing to try and do
and that's pretty much what I did I mean
when I got started I went to Emerson
College and I took a course and I took
speech courses because you had to give a
talk at the end and what I used to do
was I would memorize like a George
Carlin routine I would never say it out
loud I would memorize in my head I would
say okay I'm gonna go on a few minutes
and I would do his routine and then this
says they hit the stage I would slip
into my own experiences like I remember
he he
the clan he had the class clown album so
I would recite his jokes and then when I
hit the stage I would say you know what
I always a kid I was also a class clown
and then I would I would tell funny
stories of what everyone's about my but
I used his rhythm as the impetus to get
me into it I'm I never didn't hear
George's material but it just worked for
me as a way to it's kind of a you know
because I guess she started yeah it's
like we did married a long time you
watch porn first yeah when I was working
at Boston Globe I used to deliver the
globe yeah and I would go to the places
where I would pick up the papers and
there's a bunch of guys this guy named
uh I forgot his name he's an Indian
gentleman who is actually a
pharmacologist in India and he couldn't
get a license for it in America so he's
working as a as a paper guy the Boston
Globe a really bright guy right and you
know he would talk to me about American
culture and stuff like that I asked him
you ever heard of Sam Kinison I was
obsessed with Kennison back then yeah
this is like 86 before I ever started
doing comedy and I would I would do like
a Kennison bit for him yeah and he was
crying I was doing a bit about Sam
Kinison had a bit about dog
psychologists oh yeah yeah he goes he
goes I'd like to get in on some of that
money he goes yeah well you're having a
problem with Sparky yeah Sparky's not it
he's not acting himself I'll take care
of it first of all you're a [ __ ] dog
oh yes
you know he was a funny person horrible
guy yeah he nasty guy yeah you know
seems like and near the end he was
pulling guns on people and well there
was a used to be a bullet hole at the
Commons in the belly room sign that for
whatever reason some [ __ ] decided to
repair I was so [ __ ] mad oh yeah and
I hadn't been there in seven years and I
came back and that the the sign was
fixed ago what did you do what did you
do that wasn't bad was it was history I
can't remember if I was I'm not sure if
I put him on The Tonight Show first he
was how I was guest-hosting and I had
Sam on one time he might have been on
before that I'm not I can't I said I'm
not gonna try and take credit for that
but you know he was truly funny
just really dark I mean just nasty I
mean we're just like how so young comic
in the hall Bank just rip them I mean
way crueler than it needed to be I mean
it was and he was brilliant you know but
it's like when Sam died it was like
that's almost how he had to go out
because he was so like he had that
hilarious bit about necrophilia then
what yeah nothing funnier yeah okay so
what's your next bit okay if you have a
thing about screwing dead people what is
what's the more outrageous than this I
know right you know he kept trying to
top himself and he's able to do it you
know but it just got so crazy and then
it's that thing where you start
believing your own publicity instead of
just showing up and it's a comic you now
have an entourage Brian everything you
say is funny
you can't you know it's a comedy
perspective to be able to say to people
is this really funny or none you know no
it's not that good man
okay thanks like what is saying about
Robin you had to be able to to ask
people that question
that's why Steve Martin quit Steve
Martin yet what he talked about in his
book that he just got to a point where
just everything he said was funny and it
just he knew it was wrong he was a great
guy Steve is the one that brought Johnny
in to see me it's really yeah and I was
always very grateful for that you know I
love Steve Martin know he's a great
husband a great guy and and intelligent
guy thoughtful guy really looks at it
analytically from an artists perspective
he's really you know he's one of those
guys like I said like Johnny who looks
like a normal person but they just think
unusual and think funny in Kinison is my
favorite example that I use to young
comics when I talk about like you got to
stay the course like you can't like once
you make it it's even more hard because
once you make it then people require
things of you and you have to look at
yourself as objectively and as
analytically as you look at the whole
world
kinnison was brilliant in my opinion he
was like one of the best ever it's not
the best ever in 1986 yeah and
by 1989 he was a [ __ ] shell of
himself and well barely acceptable it
was that case of all comics like to have
some sort of open wound alcoholic drug
addict - straight - gay - something so
they have an excuse when it doesn't get
a laugh hey I did pretty good concern I
was stoned now it's pretty funny cuz I
was drinking all day before me when I
say they always need a reason why it
didn't work if it didn't work and so
consequently you get to that point where
that crutch gets bigger and bigger and
bigger you know so the idea is to try
and put that stuff aside it's a lot of
discipline being a comic you really have
to you can't believe your own publicity
I'm a huge believer in low self esteem I
think it's because when you have low
self-esteem you don't imagine
automatically think you're the smartest
one in the room right you know you just
shut up and maybe listen and take some
advice and whatever and work harder but
you know actors and criminals there's
high self-esteem the cops hadn't come
that would have been the greatest
robbery you know they all have a reason
why there's always somebody else's fall
you know and that's the thing Sam had
that Sam you worked at the crutch got
bigger and bigger and he got funnier and
funnier you needed more drugs and more
whatever - because oh that's that's why
the third show didn't work man because I
was so high okay wasn't Sam's fault he
was - huh you know it does that make any
sense you know it does I also think he
was so caught up in partying that he
never really sat down and wrote anymore
well again that's the same we're saying
the same call it partying call it
whatever you want you know the real
trick to being a comedian is is it's
it's focused you know it's a genetic
flaw that makes you a comedian it's not
nothing right it's not a plus it's a
negative I mean if you happen to live in
the time with the Crusades what who's
the soldier making all the men left kill
him all right we just happen to live in
a time when comedies advantageous but it
right you're a soldier this guy's
hysterical my men are all laughing
another pea kill that guy boom a gallop
there you go simple as that oh you
be the gesture for the king until he
decided to cut your head off and
everybody anything I was a pressure gig
- no but see that that was you know I
remember years ago when I started
tonight's show there were other guest
house on opposite me that guess how
other shows and I remember and I'd go
home every night night right and I
remember one time I turned on the news
and I saw one of the hosts at a Laker
game when I go you're not gonna have a
monologue tomorrow night I know he's not
because I'm writing jokes and he's been
at the Laker game all night and when I
watched his monologue the next night the
person didn't have any material I mean
he he got through it but it wasn't crisp
it wasn't sharp you know Ryan you have
to focus that discipline is really it's
ironic in a way because what makes you a
comic in the first place usually because
you're [ __ ] off in school and you were
the class clown you didn't have any
discipline that was me yeah I was meant
to Jay has the ability but does not
apply himself exactly verbatim I bet you
go across the board Richard Jeni you
know Dave Chappelle every [ __ ] comic
that would have the same yeah I mean I
remember my mother was called in to
school once with the guidance counselor
and I'm sitting there the guidance
counselor my brother have you ever
thought of taking Jay out of school my
mother and why and he said well you know
education is not for everyone I'm going
hello I'm in the room you work at
McDonald's after school right well they
have an excellent program with that
McDonald University you learn to make
change and run the register you know
Jesus Christ
oh yeah hilarious teachers don't I don't
know if they understand or they don't
understand but when you set an example
like that for a kid you put it in front
of them like that they're not gonna they
should drop off and take a trade or
something like that actually I credit
one of my teachers mrs. Hawkes I had
this teacher and she pulled me aside one
day and she said you know you're not a
very good student but I see you in
client I see you in the hallway and you
seem to be telling jokes and people she
says why don't you write some of these
stories down and I'll give you credit
and English class and you can read into
the class and I said oh it was the first
time in my life I really enjoyed doing a
homework I went out and I wrote the
story out now that's a and they change
line they rewrote it and I realized I'd
spent like two hours work on the
homework assignment I normally would
just been 10 minutes on and when I went
to school next day and I read it I when
it got laughs she said okay I'll give
you
I'll give you name for that and went oh
thank I mean this is a teacher taking
something that I could use in the real
world you know I'm not I'm just like
sick I'm not gonna use algebra that
we're gonna use algebra but this teacher
saw something where she said okay and
you know I set up a scholarship for and
I she passed away fairly young breast
cancer but it was it was just great
because I had never really thought about
he grew up in Andover Massachusetts
think about being a kid you think about
working in the factory or something and
I thought oh it was the first time in my
life I had used comedy and it got me
something I got an a I got an A in this
paper you know okay
so then that's how I started that's
really what got me going I used to draw
cartoons that's how I got into it is to
draw cartoons and my teachers like doing
sex acts with other students like
nature's pet or LC now you'd be sent to
prison like visual I didn't show like
genitals but you know I showed like the
Boy Scout camp when I was a kid and I
think with camp on way in New Hampshire
I went to camp in New Hampshire as a
boy's job okay okay well we had a camp
counselor mr. Butler I think his name
and this is like Cub Scouts it's like 9
10 11 and if you did something wrong for
punishment you had to stack rocks and
build the wall in front of mr. Butler's
cabin nude okay oh geez you know when
you're 9 and 10 you just you know really
I don't think that ever happened but it
was mostly and and mr. button would sit
there with his pipe and just kind of
uh-huh
yeah sit in the rocking chair and you
know it was probably East crust it's
probably eight years later I'm on like
route 495 going through Worcester it
never occurred to me because you know
when you're a kid it's skinny-dipping
all you're not thinking anything like
that it just never occurred to you that
mr. Butler's probably a pervert but once
you got older you realize oh yeah
you meet a few perverts you know this is
not the normal punishment sir I rest my
case what was about Kinison that was so
mean like what was it when you're saying
he's just a nasty person I know you know
Carla Bowe is a friend of mine but he
must have some story so he's got a
horrible story okay his child turned out
to be kinnison's child
okay so Kinnison was banging his best
friend's wife yeah behind his back and
it's it's terrible I mean and I don't
know what his relationship like is like
with the child the anemia of the stories
that you know I mean it's not the
child's fault
it's I would like to think that I would
be man enough to recognize it's not the
child's fault and not punish the child
for it and just still treat the child
like it's my child especially since
kinnison's dead but he might you know he
had been paying alimony and child
support for this for the longest time
and it's just what a betrayal to this
friend okay well there you answered your
own question with the next question yeah
that's not good yeah but I'd heard that
they did some wife swapping and [ __ ]
back then I don't know about that
complicated I just knew it was just kind
of nasty just mean is it's interesting
because that that guy just sort of
changed what comedy was for a little bit
very good it was an it was a truly
unique style nobody else had worked like
that ever I mean just as Rodney had a
style and Robin had a style a Kennison
had a style no one has had come along
before or since really with that energy
that strangeness to it it was an anger
obviously that came from and whether
abuse or religious and tolerance
whatever it was when he was a kid did
you ever read his brothers book my
brother Sam no I'd rather bill wrote a
book and it's a really good book and
it's really objective it's really it's
not like a fluff piece right and he said
that Sam got hit by I think was a car or
a truck when he was a young boy and was
never the same again and head injuries
often times lead to like very impulsive
radically different behave that would
certainly be the case there yeah he was
impulsive and radical yeah but like you
say it's it's it's a bit like that
animal with the horn grows out and
eventually curves and grows back into
its own head and it goes crazy I mean
that's kind of like what Sam was I mean
like 84 85 86
nothing bigger yeah by the early 90s it
was uh it was pretty it was why I got to
see him live after his HBO special like
almost immediately after and he didn't
really have material right he like he
had all that HBO stuff that he couldn't
really do anymore right because
everybody had seen it so now he was like
one of the first realizations that like
Wow brought this whole act for 10 years
you know worked for 10 years honed my
act developed this dis killer
power that's why you don't do HBO
specials you don't do any special no why
is that because I like to know where my
act is all the time what does that mean
but by that I mean if you want to see it
I will come to where you are and do it
there's nothing more annoying to me
people say hey I just saw sound so
special and it didn't seem that funny I
said where'd you watch it I my phone
okay you know something watching it on
your iPhone by yourself is not gonna
make you laugh okay it's not the same
you know the difference between looking
in the window of a nightclub and hearing
it and being on the other side the
window and being in the room that energy
engulfs you I mean it's part of it if
you're willing to pay attention I'll
come to where you are and I'll do it
okay I like piecemeal work right joke
tell joke get check that's pretty much
the way my life is the idea I mean I
remember we had a comic on The Tonight
Show once he said oh my HBO specials
brewing this week can you can you plug
it I said yeah okay he says then I'm
going on the road I said what material
doing the road well they don't do a lot
of stuff in the special I said you know
it's gonna be the next time he came back
like eight months later he was like oh
my god you were right people I just
heard that I heard that crap last night
cuz people watch the special before they
come see you they like you well let's
watch a special then go see him and then
they are so pissed that they spent 50
bucks or whatever it is for a ticket
that now they now they hate you
you know you so to me when you do one of
those specials you get probably a nickel
of you maybe a penny of you but when you
do a live on inch you're making 20 bucks
50 bucks but for a lot of comics that's
how they build an audience they build an
audience by putting together an HBO
special that someone who likes and then
they write a whole new
act and then when someone comes out to
see them they'll see wax that works for
some people but you know to me I always
meet people say I'm writing a new hour
and then I watch it and I go it's not an
hour that's about 16 minutes really
because there's a lot of uh-huh and oh
what else man
how y'all doing everybody good y'all
good move tonight hey how's that better
hey man I don't you know that's that's
not it's boom boom it's like it's like
throwing punches and especially old
Boston style yes and style it's very
attack like Lenny Clarke that's what I
think I mean when you get something that
works you but you got to build that
right yeah but you can build it you can
go you can do TV appearances you can do
5-minute bits you can do when people do
something for a whole hour and they
watch it boy that's a lot I mean you
give them a taste and then you come do
it in person I mean I can only say
what's worked for me right I mean it
works for me because I have jokes I
wrote yesterday I have jokes I wrote 20
years ago and they both still work
because hey I know the last time I did
this routine about this was 12 years ago
when I was in this town any idea of any
of those people being in the audience
tonight probably minimal you know if I
walk on a stage just on like I hate what
I do a talk show appearance the next
night I from in a club I make sure not
to do that material because they just
heard it yesterday right so the idea
that anybody can call up stuff that I
did at any time unless you have new
material every single day it doesn't
make sense I had this conversation with
Ari Shaffir it's a good buddy - yeah
great comedian and you know we were
talking about it and he said that when
you work on old stuff if you keep old
stuff where you tighten it up or you
keep it keeps you from expanding as an
artist and you and making stuff that's
more relevant to how you think right now
there might be something to that but it
also keeps you famous it also gets the
point people go boy I walked in and it
was a tough room and the crowd was
talking boy he got him you know again
we're talking about I'm talking about
playing hard
ticket rooms where people go who is this
guy what is it I never seen it when you
like when you play Jersey when you play
the Jersey Shore
you got 70 year old guys you got
teenagers you got grandmothers you got
longshoremen you got sale you got every
conceivable type of crime you know when
you do a comedy club your plans
essentially to the same person right
they all think alike and feel like I
mean to me I mean I like when I do I
always gear my joke some jokes about men
some about women so to me I love playing
a racially and gender diverse crowd I
hate it's all guys that's the worst I
hate oh it's all women I like it because
it keeps everybody on it's the only
releases itself you know you do a joke
about a man drew a joke but a woman to
do it and and that's what works for me
so to me I think what he's saying is
probably true I'm just talking about
making a living when you have to go
somewhere and do the job you know the
down-and-dirty part of it okay
there's the fun part of show business
and then there's a part where you've got
to go to work listen that's it's the
B'nai brif Society they're hiring you
next Wednesday they'll give me a
thousand bucks okay you've got to go
there and knock that crowd out I mean
that's what you got to do and you think
that doing special somehow or another
takes away from no I don't think special
takes away from that
I mean look I'm just talking about me no
no I know that's why I'm curious because
you're one of the few guys one of the I
consider you a great comic and you've
been doing it for everybody does you've
been doing it forever but there's very
little of your work out there I think
there's a Showtime show that I watched
from a good you did a Showtime spent
long time yeah I got that and I burned
the master but somehow that's the
opposite of what most people do most
people constantly want to put out new
stuff Carlin put out a new hour
basically every year well don't forget
see I was fortunate I had a platform
every night on The Tonight Show where I
had to do 14 minutes every single night
okay so you write 14 and then it's
probably 11 or 12 by the time it hits
here so I didn't need to do special
because I had a little tiny bit of
something out every single day a little
bit of an advertisement for people come
see okay so that's what worked for me
before I had
I made sure I did Merv Griffin Mike
Douglas weather and every four to six
weeks I would do Letterman and and and
that's how I kept it out there just give
them a little bit of a taste and when
they come to your town they're not
sticky that is interesting because you
are definitely seeing a lot of people
today that are watching stand-up from a
YouTube clip that they're watching it on
their phone and it's just not going to
be the same it's not saying you need to
experience it I you know live yeah it's
frustrating to me when I people say they
didn't think something was funny or
anything so I watched avatar on my
iPhone I think it was that great well
first of all it's a 3d movie you can't
watch it on your iPhone stop it you know
yeah it's not supposed to be convenient
it's comedies supposed to be in a room
that's a little uncomfortable it's just
a little too cold you know all the
elements that make you see like um yeah
I've tried to do comedy in Hawaii you're
standing on stage and guys and sale
fishes are going by and you know if you
know what it's the sun's out at midnight
what do you do it did you ever do
stand-up in a really really big place
like a giant arena oh sure
what do you think about that like that
seems to me like you know they do this
oddball comedy tour now and they're
doing like 20,000 seat places and you
know I thought about I was like man that
seems like a lot of goddamn people to do
stand-up for it's very strange it
depends what you like for example I like
doing stand-up so I'd rather do 10 mm
seat rooms than 120-thousand seat room
yeah I mean because I like doing it it's
fun to do you know it's fun to tell
jokes it's fun to see the person right
there when you do those 20,000 seat
things okay there's a light in your eye
and you can hear laughs but it's you're
not really experiencing it the same so
it's offensive I mean I know comics that
just Letterman was never comfortable in
front of live audience Dave was not
funny as he is he just didn't like to me
stand-up it wasn't it just he didn't
like it me I like it I like reaching out
and having the audience and that's when
the Tonight Show really came alive for
me when I redid the studio and brought
the audience right up close to me so I
could touch hands with people like right
yeah when I have something
you know whatever it might be so I like
it I like the human contact you know
stand up it's probably the most basic
form of human communication
there's no with the exception of the
microphone that's it there's no trick
there's no gimmick it's just humans
interacting you know the other reason I
like stand-up is people don't gather
anymore you know when I grew up an end
over once a month they would have the
town meeting at the Grange Hall which is
dumb as that sound in North Andover and
the whole town would show up nothing
ever got done but people gathered in a
room and it was fun to experience a room
full of people laughing or reacting to
something now everybody taxes or sits
there's a social awkwardness to the
iPhone but when you put people in a
little room it's a little uncomfortable
in the yelling staging you talk to them
and that room is rolling with laughs
it's really the greatest thing in the
world it's it's unbelievable
yeah I agree I think it's an amazing art
form it's the most fun for me to watch
as well as to do I loved I loved
watching it I still love sitting in the
back of the saw Tom Papa last night he
was Hilaire
comas really good at name he's so funny
and you know I got to sit in the back of
the room after I got off stage and watch
him at the back of the comedy store I'm
like I just still love it as an art form
I mean to me it's like listening to
music you know I meant when I first met
Letterman I didn't really know Dave and
I saw him at the Comedy Store and Dave
had a great way to turn a phrase I
remember he had I don't do the joke
justice he said I joke about he was
talking about editorials on small-town
TV stations and we at w-whatever are
diametrically opposed to the practice of
using orphans as yardage markers on
public golf courses something like that
and I thought I just like the way he
phrased it to me that's like listening
to a James Taylor song just the way all
those words come together you know when
Seinfeld used to have a bit about going
to the dodgem cars that the and the
hopeless father-and-son team and I like
hopeless father inside so I just like
the way they phrase things so to me
listening to good comedy I can listen to
it over and over yeah no I agree I
I love listening to the way certain
people phrase things and like you were
saying about how you going onstage after
listening and reciting Carlin in your
head how it sort of helped you like that
rhythm and cadence you know 100 Thompson
used to do that he used to write The
Great Gatsby he used to write it out
like just copy The Great Gatsby to sort
of learn the rhythm of the words yeah I
think a lot of us have experienced going
on stage and sort of feeling like you're
doing someone else's cadence and rhythm
I caught myself once too one time on
stage at the comedy connection and I
felt like I was in the middle of doing
Richard Jeni I was like I was being
Richard Jeni while I was on stage I was
like Oh like I'm kind of stealing this
guy's he was one of the best that that
people don't talk about he was one of
those guys that sort of the guys of
today maybe don't realize how great that
guy was he really was yeah he was one of
the best at taking a bit and stretching
it out - I love his bit on gay marriage
you know this is before gay marriage is
illegal obviously and he used to a bit
about how great it was for gay guys Bob
I'd love to marry you but it's against
the law it used to really make me laugh
look Steve I'd love to but it's against
the law it was the perfect guy excuse
not to get married it's against the law
and he would take a bit and stretch it
out over seven ten minutes I mean he
would find every single nook and cranny
that that could be very more any guy but
it's not of insecure but very funny he
was troubled yeah he was troubled like
Manny but so disciplined yes constantly
working constantly writing new Messiah
fellas like that very discipline really
writes and comes up with new stuff and
you can see the difference - you can see
the jokes come every six to nine seconds
verses every 30 seconds or some guy hey
y'all good mood how y'all doing yeah get
to the joke right right right yeah
that's that's that old-school attitude
to that people don't have a lot of
attention they just they don't have much
time for this
go go go go go Seinfeld's one of the few
guys that rivals you as a
our collector - I'm not quite he's a
Porsche guy he only Portuguese an expert
now he's got some German self Mercedes
but but he's a real expert he knows his
stuff yeah that comedians in cars
getting coffee is a very interesting
shop it's a great show it's really fun
you know everybody tells you you can do
Gary's a perfect example the Seinfeld
show about nothing now nobody's gonna
watch that and biggest show of ever when
he had this idea I would just drive
around we just talked about every want
no no you got to have it all laid out
first no you don't and he proved that
you didn't need to well that's what's
going on with the internet is that you
don't the idea that these producers and
executives and directors have always had
that run networks that this is the only
way to be entertaining they're wrong
it's just another way to but you watch
it'll come full circle again and people
go I'm sick of this freeform stuff I
want something a little more you know
say just it's just the age you live in
most people do this show and they make
it about an hour maybe an hour and 20
before they have to take a leak yeah you
look like you're about right there
what's as long as you want it to be oh
we could end it right now if you like I
got a meeting at 1:00 but let's let's
wrap it up then okay we'll wrap it up
thank you very much for having me
anytime you ever want to come back again
I would be more than honored to have you
call me and I'm here it was an honor to
do your show I love your show Jay Leno's
Garage my episode is on this week with
my 1965 Corvette and it was an honor to
come and tour your facility and send
with the Chevelle and the and they
absolutely absolutely love you buddy
thanks I appreciate it
[Music]